I think that YouTube's blurring the
lines between like film strictly film
and you know it's online media I mean
dr. horrible's sing-along blog won an
Emmy so anything can really happen from
the internet I do think it's interesting
because there are things that are huge
within YouTube that you know don't even
really register on the mainstream don't
and so I think that just because
something is on online doesn't
necessarily going to hear your product
and doesn't necessarily mean that you
you look down on it is credited the
thing is with online video its
interactive it was it's not necessarily
a filmmaking media
social media needs me
and I feel that has advantage because
it's talking to the audience
communicating its giving what the
audience
then creating some abstract concept that
somebody thinks I've been watching
YouTube videos to the past
since 2007 watching with others and
since then I'm just I think her fellow
like I'm subscribe to about a hundred
and six
it's all going it's all going here this
is whether whether they realize it or
not whether they're going to fight it or
not they're not going to be able to
fight it because this is where it's
going to be it's putting its put in it
back to anyone anyone can do this and
anyone gets to choose now and it's not
about oh you got to watch what the
networks are giving you you know
you get to decide and yeah when I was
young I remember hearing something about
oh there's going to be thousands of
channels and you're gonna is going to be
unlimited content and you know I was
like wow what's not going to be like you
know and here we are you know it's like
everyone's got their own channel and
and the people decide what they like and
the people decide what so whoever's
making content right now it doesn't want
it doesn't think that they should get to
YouTube they're going to become a
dinosaur's I'm going to become extinct
and look at Jimmy Kimmel like he's
totally on the internet that's like you
know and he discovered me and for a
reason because he's seen as smart he
sees what's coming and smart really
smart people they can see into the
future because all they got to do is get
the stuff that's around them and add it
all up and see oh yeah this is this is
this happens this is going to happen
it's just not you know so if you can
just do mad if you can just be smart and
see what's going on at work what what's
trending and what's you know the things
that are coming it's obvious that you
have to embrace this or you won't exist
well we went to film school where from
school that's the whole or what we're
taught nobody would dare as a professor
say oh you guys you know you guys should
go make stuff on YouTube and just put it
on the Internet make whatever you want
it's fun nobody says that those are not
in our films not in our film school and
our film school it was make these pieces
of art send them to these festivals and
that was about the only way to do it and
so I mean everybody everybody I think we
left film school at least where we went
had that same mentality of even though
YouTube sounds fun you can't use his
profession because nobody has been
talking how to use it as a profession
now looking back and then we both agree
if somebody had told us how to use
YouTube back five years ago we could
have been like phenomenally successful
like without even trying anymore because
we just would have come in at the right
time at the began of the gold rush of
YouTube as a new medium and that I think
was really important it's still
available medium it's just now
everybody's figured it out it's
saturated so it's a little harder now I
think it was but knowing that I could
have spent you know four years making
YouTube videos instead of potato
classrooms going to make films and go
about paying a ton of money and owing a
lot of people more interest and I've
never sent a thing to a festival either
so all that strategy I've never even
done I have I didn't get accepted very
often once like once
now we know that over a year you can
make a youtube channel 22 million views
which I could never get from festering
yeah
you live and you learn I think it's good
to both I think it's good to do the
traditional model and try to get it seen
because you're going to get it seen by a
different audience and different people
but I think it's also good to make sure
you get it out there so as many people
can see it as possible so i would
recommend put it in festivals if that's
what you want to do but at the same time
don't be afraid to spread through
I know if you want to make a a minute
video and you know put it in theaters or
submitted film festivals that's awesome
you know that's really cool just like
don't look down on youtubers if they
want to make a name in a video put it on
YouTube I mean there's a difference you
know you took definitely
because i don't feel like i am i am
making something
special like I don't feel like I'm doing
anything so I just talked to a camera
and I like to contact me that way and I
talked to people around the world I'm
from Denmark I live in bed
and I had so many friends over here now
other places too just because of you two
YouTube itself is a really big community
so people give me feedback on my videos
and say like this is what I like this is
what i'd like to see and i can say okay
well then I'll do that for you and like
give you some content and I feel like
it's our job to kind of like say like oh
you're giving us something like here's
some great content maybe say this is
what I really liked about or maybe next
time try a different lighting or
something like that like I feel like
it's our responsibility because we're
being entertained to give a feedback or
else is just like a one-way street and
some more in-depth take a life I think
compared to a film to gain the same
there's so much in a film you
admittedly each video is a short amount
of time when you subscribe to the
channel you can get constant updates
problem and it's like progressing a
story that is someone's life and it can
definitely like the videos can teach you
a lot about
any ideology that they have or like
values and stuff like that and you can
live
so it's not less legitimate as the
finals in a bit more casual filmmaking
is great you know it's awesome but
there's so much effort is so much time
that the money that you guys putting
that not everybody has those resources
there's like it was like special
equipment and the time and money that
old I mean they don't have that time so
it's a lot like more convenient for them
to take you to me is i do parody stuff
in your school numbers and things like
that comedy and stuff I know you can do
that in the festival circuit but having
to spend the money to do a proper film
we'll say proper film is so much harder
to come up with then being able to work
on youtube with no budget and I can put
it up for free and all it takes for me
in order to get it out to people is
maybe trying to get onto some blogs yes
I send it to a couple of video game
websites and say hey you've never seen
something like this take a look and
video game websites say you're right
I've never seen that before yeah i'm
going to post this all the people that
come to my site all day are going to be
clicking on it watching and sharing with
their friends so I think if I were into
things that didn't have a market on the
internet I would have to start looking
at things like festivals again but but
luckily we do silly drama things and I
mean we do musical numbers so it's like
even if you're not interested in
watching our video you're probably still
in you might be interested in just
listening to it so we have a bunch of
subscribers who are just like yeah so I
threw this on my ipod and listen to it
every day in the car with theirs we're
going to anime expo tomorrow and there
was like this group of playing
final fantasy guys we're like so we
downloaded your your video onto our ipod
we're gonna be all singing it in the car
as we're driving it in in the final
fantasy cosplay to anime expo yeah and
so it's a totally different mentality
then film have been a you know film
festival or traditional medium where
it's like you go here you watch the
thing and it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't leave that area whereas with you
with YouTube I feel like we're getting
more of this interactivity yeah yeah fan
interaction
it's not fair to just say like oh
because we don't have the funds it's
really hard to pitch a film to any
company because everyone's looking for
money you look at like summer movies
they're all franchises sequels prequels
so it's really hard to pitch a film you
of YouTube is just make it and put it
out there and get an audience and some
people make short films and from there
get funding to make actual film so they
give them like submit to the Oscars or
something so I think YouTube is really
fostering you know young minds and
filmmakers and everyone and to look down
upon that it's not fair and it's really
stupid honestly